This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）带来的《艰难一课》。这个节目聚焦于黑人男性的生活经历，进行那些在其他地方根本不敢进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披一副铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你可不是好惹的。这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须去使用它。请收听《艰难一课》，
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
在iHeart电台应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2%。这是指在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、体能以及复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在经历之后迎来一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的自己。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个声名狼藉的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他必须得到应得的下场。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
请在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信我，宝贝》。在《回溯往昔》播客节目中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说都是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当年发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Before we get into this episode, I do want to let you know that this conversation does include discussions of domestic violence.
和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回溯往昔》。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客节目中，我们探讨20多岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。在进入本期节目之前，我想提醒大家，今天的对话确实涉及家庭暴力的话题。
and sexual abuse. There will be resources in the description of this episode if you need or require further help or information, but listener discretion is advised. Hello everybody and welcome back to the podcast. Welcome back to the show, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. Today, we have an incredible story, an incredible guest on the show to share their experience with overcoming adversity and hardship, mainly a trauma and an event that happened during their 20s. I think it's always phenomenal and a good idea to view our lives as more than this
和性虐待。如果您需要或想要进一步的帮助或信息，本期节目的简介中将提供相关资源，但建议听众谨慎收听。大家好，欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到节目中，新听友、老听友，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。今天，我们请来了一位不可思议的嘉宾，她将在节目中分享她克服逆境和苦难的经历，主要是她在20多岁时经历的一次创伤和一个事件。我认为，将我们的人生视作超越这一个
decade and receive the import from someone who has lived through their 20s, lived through some incredibly hard things, and come through it so that they can teach us, teach us the way and show us that there is a path forward. So Amy, it is so amazing to have you on the show. Can you introduce yourself for the audience? Oh, Lord. You know, it's funny. I don't get nervous often, but I don't know why. I'm a little nervous right now. That was quite the introduction and such a beautiful, you know, space to enter. So thank you. I, my name is Amy B. Chessler, and I am an author, a podcaster, a mom, first and foremost, to be honest, I should have said that first. and I am a victim advocate.
十年的存在，并倾听一个已经度过20多岁、经历过极其艰难的事情并最终走出来的人的见解，永远是一个绝佳且明智的主意，这样他们就能教导我们，指引方向，并向我们展示前方确实有一条路。所以艾米，非常高兴你能来到节目中。你能为听众做个自我介绍吗？哦，天哪。你知道，这挺搞笑的。我不常紧张，但我不知道为什么。我现在有点紧张。这真是一个隆重的开场，也是一个非常美好的交流空间，非常谢谢你。我，我的名字是艾米·B·切斯勒（Amy B. Chessler），我是一名作家、播客主持人，说实话，首先我更是一位母亲，我应该先把这个身份说出来。我还是一名受害者权益倡导者。
I often start by sharing my story by saying I am a victim and also a survivor of domestic violence. My mother, however, is not. She did not survive the domestic violence we faced. So just I guess a long story short, because I do believe my upbringing led to me, led me to the culmination of a lot of abuse and trauma in my early 20s. But long story short, I was raised by a very tenacious, strong single mother. I grew up in Calabasas, California, so like the Kardashians, which was not reality. Again, like there's a lot of reality TV made about the place, but it's not a reality-based place. However, I was raised by a single mom, and we didn't have a lot of means.
我经常用这样一句话来分享我的故事：我既是家庭暴力的受害者，也是幸存者。然而，我的母亲却不是。她没有在我们要面对的家庭暴力的中幸存下来。所以简而言之，因为我相信我的成长经历导致了我20岁出头时遭遇的大量虐待和创伤的累积。但长话短说，我是由一位极其顽强、坚强的单亲妈妈抚养长大的。我在加利福尼亚州的卡拉巴萨斯长大，就像卡戴珊家族那样，那可不是现实生活。再说一次，有很多关于那个地方的真人秀电视节目，但那并不是一个基于现实的地方。不过，我是由单亲妈妈抚养长大的，我们当时并没有多少积蓄。
My brother was ostracized there because, you know, again, In the 80s, 90s, we didn't have the cool stuff that everybody else had. We kind of were just scraping by. We were latchkey kids. And we both got picked on a lot, but he just kind of never found a place to fit in. That developed and turned into abuse over the years. He scapegoated. My mom and I, I believe, for a lot of the feelings he was feeling.
我的哥哥在那里备受排挤，因为，你知道的，在80-90年代，我们没有其他人拥有的那些酷炫的东西。我们差不多只是勉强度日。我们都是挂着钥匙上学的小孩。我们俩都经常被欺负，但他只是从来没有找到一个能融入进去的地方。多年来，这种排挤逐渐演变成了虐待。我认为，他把内心的很多感受都归咎于我和妈妈，
My dad was never really in the picture. In fact, my mom likes to tell me I was the last time they had sex. So, like I was conceived that time. I never actually lived with my father. I guess I was probably a lot less affected by his absence because I had never even known his presence. My brother was deeply affected by it because he left when he was three. So just from then on, he kind of was an angry-ass person. He really directed a lot of the anger towards myself and my mom.
我父亲从来没有真正出现在我们的生活中。事实上，我妈妈喜欢告诉我，我是他们最后一次发生性关系时怀上的。所以我就是那个时候被孕育出来的。我实际上从未与父亲住在一起。我想，对于他的缺席，我受到的影响可能要小得多，因为我甚至从未感受过他的存在。我哥哥受到的影响很深，因为在他三岁时父亲就离开了。所以从那时起，他基本上就成了一个脾气暴躁的人。他真的把很多怒火都发泄在了我和妈妈身上。
He abused me in many different ways over the years. The abuse started around when I was probably 10 or 11. I say that like the abuse was environmental where he would get really angry and punch holes in the walls. He was really volatile. He was really moody. Then actually the abuse became sexual and he sexually abused me as a child. That was when I was around 12. And it took me decades to figure out what he had done because his abuse was so shrewd.
多年来，他以各种不同的方式虐待我。虐待大约始于我10岁或11岁的时候。我这么说是因为那种虐待就像是环境造成的，他会变得非常生气，然后在墙上砸洞。他的情绪非常不稳定。他的喜怒无常。后来，虐待实际上变成了性虐待，他在我还是个孩子的时候就对我进行了性虐待。那大概是在我12岁的时候。我花了数十年时间才弄清楚他对我做过什么，因为他的虐待实在是太狡猾了。
And I share like, I don't generally like to share that like the intimate. details of it live because I write about it more than anything because again as much as I digest all this trauma for other not for content and awareness and all that um yeah I get to choose the boundaries of that uh so my boundary generally but yeah that that was extremely devastating it kind of manifested when that ended a year later when I was around 13 he became extremely violent and angry ended up dropping out of high school and ended up going in and out of the army a couple times
我分享……我通常不喜欢在直播中分享那些私密的细节，因为比起其他任何事情，我更愿意把它写下来，因为同样地，尽管我消化所有这些创伤是为了别的目的，而不是为了内容和关注度之类的一切，嗯，是的，我可以为之设定界限，所以我的界限通常是……但是是的，那绝对是毁灭性的。当那件事在一阵子之后结束时，大约在我13岁的时候，他变得极其暴力和愤怒，最终从高中辍学，并且数次进出军队。
the U.S. Army and just really could never find a place in life. My mom bled him in and out. An abusive relationship is really hard. We know the toxicity. We know the cyclical nature of it. Now there's a lot more language we have
美国陆军，只是真的在生活中找不到自己的方向。我妈妈曾让他进进出出。一段虐待关系真的很艰难。我们都了解那种毒性。我们了解它的循环本质。现在我们掌握的语言要丰富得多，
than when we did in 2007, at the height of our abuse. Eventually, unfortunately, the abuse got so bad. He threatened my mom's life several times and eventually killed her. On September 25th, 2007, the exact date actually became America's national murder victims' Remembrance Day. Like her exact murder date. But that was coincidental.
比起我们在2007年我们遭受虐待最严重的时候。最终，不幸的是，虐待变得极其严重。他多次威胁我妈妈的生命，并最终杀害了她。2007年9月25日，这个确切的日期实际上成为了美国的全国谋杀受害者纪念日。就像她遇害的确切日期一样。但那只是个巧合。
I didn't find that out for many years. However, that day after he did argument, he stole her life. I came home to find her, even though he had told me he had killed her on my drive. home. I had reached him. He told me not to go home. I didn't really believe him because of his the nature of his abuse and his kind of cycle of behavior. It was so up and down. He would sometimes joke about stuff like that. I know that sounds really weird. And I've gotten a lot of slack on about that on the internet because people just don't understand how that's possible for me to hear that and think he was joking. But when you live in constant abuse or fear, sometimes,
我很多年以后才发现这一点。然而，在那天发生争执后，他剥夺了她的生命。我回到家找到了她，尽管他在我回家的路上就已经告诉过我他杀了我妈妈。我联系过他。他告诉过我不要回家。因为他虐待的本质以及他那种行为的周期性，我其实并没有真正相信他。他的情绪起伏太大了。他有时会拿这种事情开玩笑。我知道这听起来真的很奇怪。我在互联网上也因此受到了很多抨击，因为人们根本不理解我怎么可能听到那种话还觉得他在开玩笑。但当你生活在持续的虐待或恐惧中时，有时，
those things are jokes. And that's a mechanism of coercive control that I've now, you know, identified with time. But so when I was 22, my brother murdered my mother. It was shocking. It was gutting. It threw me for a major damn loop. I found many mechanisms of healing afterwards, some healthy, some not. And now that I am 38, I have a great.
那些事情会被当成笑话。而这正是胁迫性控制的一种机制，随着时间的推移，我现在已经能够识别出来了。所以在我22岁的时候，我哥哥谋杀了我母亲。这太令人震惊了，太痛彻心扉了。它把我彻底搞崩溃了。事后我找到了许多疗愈的机制，有些是健康的，有些则不然。现在我38岁了，我拥有了极好的、
grand perspective of our experiences. My degree going into that, you know, my brother actually killed her two weeks before, two weeks after I graduated college. And my degree is in psychology. So I actually went on in all of that in my healing, went on to start my MFT. I did drop out because I realized it just wasn't exactly where I wanted to be. But I think I utilize psychology and obviously I utilize my own healing journey in my work, in my advocacy, and my sharing in my endeavors. And it's just,
宏观的视角来看待我们的经历。在那之前，我的学位……你知道的，我哥哥实际上是在我大学毕业两周前、两周后杀害了她的。我的学位是心理学。所以在经历这一切以及我的疗愈过程中，我实际上继续去攻读婚姻与家庭治疗（MFT）硕士学位。我中途辍学了，因为我意识到这并不完全是我想要的方向。但我认为我将心理学，当然还有我自己的疗愈之旅运用到了我的工作、我的倡导活动以及我的努力中。而且这真的是，
yeah, it's been a bit of a mind fuck, the journey that I've gone on since then. I can imagine. And all of that is just so terrible. Obviously, we've spoken about it before, but it's just every time you tell me,
是的，自从那以后，我所经历的这段旅程简直太操蛋了。我完全能想象。这一切都太可怕了。显然，我们以前谈论过这个，但每次你告诉我，
I literally just get like this, terrible feeling in my stomach that you had to live through that because it's yeah no words really no words and I like to add too is that the nature of my podcast not to plug it so earlier talk about it but the nature of my podcast is it's called what came next because quite literally people think that victims endeavors or journeys or hardships kind of end with the trauma and then we get to heal but the idea is that there's always something coming next so we'd like to think that like I like you said thank you I mean thank you for acknowledging that however the trauma didn't even end there with him yeah um you know the nature of our and I think it's important
我真的就会有一种这种感觉，胃里翻江倒海般的糟糕感觉，因为你不得不经历那些，因为真的……无需多言，真的无需多言。我想补充一点，我的播客的性质——不是为了给它打广告，刚才只是聊到了——我播客的性质是它叫做《接下来发生了什么》（What Came Next），因为很显然，人们认为受害者的努力、旅程或苦难会在创伤发生时结束，然后我们就开始疗愈，但其实它的理念是永远有下一步会发生。所以我们总觉得，就像你说的，谢谢你，我的意思是，谢谢你对此表示认可，然而创伤甚至没有随着他而结束，是的，嗯，你知道我们性质的……并且我认为了解这一点很重要，
to know that like the nature of our criminal justice system allows for I think I believe the correct term is litigation abuse so my brother was caught that evening he was admittedly guilty but it took four and a half years to convict him and the last ditch effort he made before he actually got convicted or actually pled no contest to second degree murder in 2011, I believe, was he tried to hire a hitman to kill me. He tried to pin the murder on me, say, I planned everything. I, like, promised him a huge lump of money that I didn't have. Like, I don't know where he was coming up with any of this shit and basically told this
我们刑事司法系统的性质允许存在——我想正确的术语应该是“诉讼虐待”——所以我的哥哥在那天晚上被抓获，他供认不讳，但定罪花了四年半的时间。他在被定罪或在2011年左右对二级谋杀不予抗辩之前做出的最后挣扎，我没记错的话，是他试图雇佣杀手来杀我。他试图把谋杀罪嫁祸给我，说是我策划了一切。我，比如，承诺给他一大笔我根本没有的钱。就像，我不知道他脑子里是从哪儿冒出这些狗屁倒灶的事情的，他基本上把这个在监狱里即将出狱的狱友，或者说，
inmate in jail that was getting out or, you know, potentially being released. like, hey, my sister did all this shit. Can you try to stalk her? He created like a stalking plan for him. And then he said like off the record like, hey, if you don't do it, if she doesn't do it, if she doesn't admit to what I'm saying she should admit to, just wipe her out, basically. So that was like a continued abuse from within jail. He eventually pled guilty.
可能即将获释的狱友叫到跟前，说，嘿，我妹妹干了这些破事。你能试着跟踪她吗？他甚至为那个人制定了一个跟踪计划。然后他私下里说，嘿，如果你不这么做，如果她不这么做，如果她不承认我所说她应该承认的话，那就直接把她做掉，基本上就是这样。所以那是一种来自监狱内部的持续虐待。他最终认罪了。
And then I only got nine and a half years before his first parole hearing. And those nine and a half years I kind of had that like looming death threat over my head, I guess. I had always thought that like maybe I gave him a lot of power in those years, I think, that I shouldn't have, that I didn't have the tools to not give. I was definitely suffering with some severe PTSD lingering after all of that. So I think I don't even think I started healing until 2011 when I was about 26, which is my mom's lucky number. So there we go. Oh, that's sweet. That's very sweet. I've never really thought about that. Look at that. 26 is a special number, honestly. And because you were 22 when it happened. So that's, we said this before, but that's, you were just still basically a child, you know, technically and adult.
然后距离他的第一次假释听证会，我只得到了九年半的安稳日子。在过去的九年半里，那种挥之不去的死亡威胁一直压在我心头，我想。我一直觉得，在那些年里，我可能赋予了他太多的权力，我觉得这是我不该给的，是我当时没有工具去拒绝的。经历了这一切之后，我确实一直在遭受严重的创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的困扰。所以我想，直到2011年我大约26岁时，我才真正开始疗愈，这也是我妈妈的幸运数字。所以你看。哦，这太甜了。这非常甜蜜。我从来没有真正想过这一点。你看。26岁真的是个特殊的数字，说实话。而且因为你出事时才22岁。所以，我们之前说过，你当时基本上还是个孩子，你知道的，从技术上讲是个成年人。
But it's still in that formative decade. Well, the ironic thing is, is that my brother always got the comfort of a youth offender status because he killed my mom when he was 25 years old and 90. months instead of 26. 26 in America is the number that we I guess the law sees your brain from fully formed and so I guess now I'm putting all these pieces together I didn't even realize that was 26 when he was technically sentenced and that's kind of interesting all these like alignments but yeah there's a lot of different little weird alignments that I've gone through similar traumas at the same time that my mom did um or just similar kind of like yeah anyway grief and trauma never really does leave the body. No. As we know. So it's just amazing to still see you doing really well and your show is
但它仍然发生在我们成型的十年里。嗯，具有讽刺意味的是，我哥哥总是能享受到青年违法者的身份待遇，因为他杀害我妈妈时是25岁零90个月，而不是26岁。在美国，26岁是我们——我想法律认为你的大脑完全发育成熟的年龄——所以我想现在我正在把这些碎片拼凑起来，我甚至没有意识到当他被判刑时正好是26岁，这挺有趣的，所有这些契合点……但是是的，我经历过很多不同的小小的奇怪契合点，在相似的时间经历过与我妈妈相似的创伤，或者只是类似的，是的，无论如何，悲伤和创伤确实永远不会离开身体。不会的。正如我们所知。所以，看到你现在依然过得很好，而且你的节目
incredible. But I do want to ask, you know, this, this is a show about your 20s. Yeah. This is a major, I would say, defining event and defining experience of your whole life, but your 20s is when it culminated. Yeah. So looking back on that, what would you, what would you tell her now, this young person who's just lived? through possibly the most life-changing thing to ever happen to her. Oh, goodness. Well, that's a really big question. You're making me tear up.
令人惊叹，这真的很棒。但我想问，你知道，这是一档关于你20多岁的节目。是的。这是你整个人生中一个重大、可以说是决定性的事件和决定性的经历，但你的20多岁正是这一切达到顶峰的时期。是的。所以回首过去，你会对现在的她——这个刚刚经历过可能是她一生中最具改变人生意义的事情的年轻女孩——说些什么？哦，天哪。这是一个非常宏大的问题。你让我快要落泪了。
But I think a lot of abuse survivors carry a lot of shame and guilt, and as much as I don't anymore at all, I've done a lot of hard work in a deep digging. I think I would just tell her that I love her and that none of it is their fault. I never shared about the sexual abuse of my mom. So I always thought when it happened initially that when I was 22 and my mom was murdered, I initially immediately thought, God, if I had reported that, my mom would be alive today because she would have created a harder boundary with my brother knowing how bad the abuse was towards me.
但我认为很多虐待幸存者都背负着大量的羞耻感和内疚感，尽管我现在完全没有了，我已经做了很多艰苦的工作和深入的挖掘。我想我会告诉她我爱她，这一切都不是她的错。我从未向我妈妈透露过性虐待的事。所以当它最初发生时，当我在22岁、我妈妈被谋杀时，我最初的第一反应是，天哪，如果我当时报警了，我妈妈今天就会活得好好的，因为她会更坚决地划清界限，如果她知道我受到的虐待有多严重的话。
I always, she was my fiercest advocate. So I thought in not advocating for myself, I didn't advocate for her too. I have had to, there's this very like religious tentate that people have to have to. forgive their abusers. I don't believe in that. That's some bullshit. I believe in forgiving your younger self in allowing, quote, unquote, although that is not really allowing. You are being abused, but that is the sentiment that usually that is a victim, you know, we think, oh gosh, I've allowed this.
我一直认为，她是我最坚定的捍卫者。所以我想，由于我没有为自己维权，我也就没能为她维权。我不得不——人们有一种非常宗教化的清规戒律，那就是必须原谅虐待自己的人。我不相信这个。那纯属放屁。我相信的是原谅年幼时的自己，去允许，所谓的“允许”——尽管这并不真的是允许。你当时正在遭受虐待，但这就是通常受害者会有的那种情绪，
I have to allow healing and forgiveness to that young girl who didn't have the tools and resources to establish the boundaries that she needed. And I all, that's what I give myself every day. I also, something I say to that young lady, I talk to her every day, quite honestly. You know, that sounds crazy, but I. It doesn't. Well, I believe in being mindful and I believe in having healthy schemas in your head. The way you talk to yourself is of utmost importance. And the way I talked to myself at that time was not healthy.
我们觉得，哦天哪，我怎么能容忍这个。我必须对自己年轻时那个缺乏工具和资源来建立所需界限的女孩给予宽恕和谅解。而我一直，我每天都这样对自己。还有，我对那个年轻女孩说的话——老实说，我每天都跟她说话。你知道，这听起来很疯狂，但我……这并不疯狂。嗯，我崇尚正念，我坚信在头脑中拥有健康的思维模式。你跟自己说话的方式至关重要。我当时对自己说话的方式并不健康。
A lot of young women in the world and a lot of young people in general, not just women, do not speak health. I don't think our society in general breeds too much mental health innately. And so I constantly talk to her by healing how I speak about myself. And in that, I'm speaking to her too. And I'm just like, I tell myself a badass all the time. I say, I forgive you. I love you. You are safe now.
世上有很多年轻女性，还有很多年轻人总体来说，不仅仅是女性，并不懂得如何健康地跟自己对话。我认为我们的社会总体上并不能天生孕育出太多的心理健康。所以我通过改变自己谈论自己的方式，不断地与她对话来进行疗愈。在那种对话中，其实也是在对她说话。我一直在告诉自己我是一个狠角色。我说，我原谅你。我爱你。你现在安全了。
Look at you. Look how far you've come. I love the tenets of healing your inner child. and I did an entire episode on it. It's my favorite episode because I think there is this misconception that it's really wishy-washy, that it's a pseudoscience. But positive self-talk and healing your inner child is so based in so much psychological theory, it goes back for decades.
看看你。看看你已经走了多远。我喜欢疗愈内心小孩的那些信条，我甚至为此做了一整期节目。这是我最喜欢的节目，因为我认为人们有一种误解，觉得这非常不着边际，是一种伪科学。但积极的自我对话和疗愈内心小孩是有着深厚心理学理论基础的，它可以追溯到几十年前。
And I just think it's a beautiful practice to visualize your younger self and care for them. because they're still within you. That version of you has not disappeared. You are not replaced each year that you age. So I really, really like that you brought that up. I have to ask something, though. Do you think that a part of your struggle was also survivor's guilt or the fact that you felt that you could have saved your mother? No, I never really thought about that.
我认为可视化自己年幼时的样子并照顾他们是一种美妙的做法。因为他们仍然在你体内。随着你年龄的增长，那个版本的你并没有消失。你并没有被你长大的每一年所取代。所以我真的很喜欢你提出这一点。不过我得问一个问题。你认为你的挣扎中有一部分也是幸存者内疚，或者是因为你觉得自己本可以救你的妈妈吗？不，我从来没有真正想过这个。
To be honest, I know that sounds a little callous or selfish perhaps, but I knew the mechanism of abuse was all my brother's hands. I had seen his volatility and his violence for so long. I knew that was all his, right? Like, I didn't really, I didn't think, like, I never actually thought, because I always thought if I had been there that night and he had lost it, I'd be dead too, to be honest. So I get to carry on. And I don't have survivors guilt. I have survivors' responsibility, perhaps, in making her death not in vain, in making my efforts heard, in trying to change whatever I can by, you using our story as an example. My mom was a teacher. I used to be a teacher before I turned in the towel and actually, well, I had my own kids, but I also was like in my having my children,
老实说，我知道这听起来可能有点冷酷或自私，但我深知虐待的机制完全是由我哥哥一手造成的。我太久地目睹了他的喜怒无常和暴力。我知道那全都是他的问题，对吧？所以，我其实并没有——我从没真正想过，因为我一直觉得如果那天晚上我在场而他彻底失控了，我也死定了，说实话。所以我得以活下来。我没有幸存者内疚。或许我拥有的是幸存者责任感，我要让她的死不白白牺牲，让我的努力被听到，试图通过以我们的故事作为榜样来改变我所能改变的一切。我妈妈是一名教师。在转行之前我曾经也是一名教师，嗯，其实，在拥有我自己的孩子之前，但我也在生孩子的同时意识到，
I knew I had a lot to heal. I had kids in my 20s as well. I was 28 when I had children. So that is super formative too. I never thought I would have children in my 20s. I had so many conversations with my mom growing up saying I would not have kids until I'm at least 30. And then I went through this massive trauma and all I wanted to do was recreate a healthy family system or not even recreate because I don't think we ever had that with him. Maybe when we were very young. But my brother was just always, always beyond reach for her and abused her. It was a really toxic relationship. So I think my 20s and being free from the murder, I mean from my brother.
我知道我有很多创伤需要疗愈。我在20多岁时也生了孩子。所以这也是超级具有成型意义的。我从未想过会在20多岁时生孩子。我成长过程中曾和妈妈有过无数次对话，说我至少要到30岁才生孩子。然后我经历了这场巨大的创伤，我唯一想做的就是重建一个健康的家庭系统，甚至不是重建，因为我认为我们从来没有和他拥有过那种系统。也许在我们很小的时候有过。但我的哥哥对她来说总是遥不可及，而且一直在虐待她。那是一段非常糟糕的关系。所以我认为我的20多岁，在摆脱了谋杀之后——我的意思是摆脱了我哥哥之后——
Unfortunately, at the loss of my mom really. it knocked me for a loop. It was fucking traumatic beyond belief. What I saw I wouldn't like wish on any of my worst enemies but it changed my life ultimately I got freed
不幸的是，是以失去我妈妈为代价的。这让我彻底崩溃了。这简直是难以置信的操蛋的创伤。我所看到的那些，我绝不会希望发生在我的任何死敌身上，但它最终改变了我的生活。我终于从
from my lifetime abuser. I finally got up. So yeah. It's a big cost though I guess. It's very layered. It's very layered. Very nuanced. I just can imagine I just can't imagine what it would be like to be in your head stepping through all those different scenarios
终身虐待我的人手中解脱了。我终于站起来了。所以，是的。不过我想代价很大。这非常有层次感。非常微妙。我简直无法想象，在你的脑海里，经历所有这些不同的场景
and all those different outcomes and consequences. I will say 16 years later, obviously the way I talk about it and navigate it is a bit different than I was than I couldn't talk about it and navigate it. I was surviving. So it's just definitely interesting, the perspective I've gained. It's very intricate. And I wonder, you've already mentioned this about how it changed your life, really. And now you do so much work around victim and survivor advocacy.
以及所有这些不同的结局和后果，会是什么感觉。我想说，16年过去了，显然我谈论和应对它的方式与过去有所不同。我当时是在求生。所以，我所获得的视角绝对是非常有趣的。它非常错综复杂。我想知道，你已经提到过这如何真正改变了你的生活。现在你围绕受害者和幸存者权益倡导做了大量工作，
and you have this entire show that is dedicated to extending the story or sharing, I guess, more of the side of the story that isn't always made available. But how do you think it's kind of changed your perspective and your mindset on life? Do you think that it obviously has had an impact, but in what way? You hit me so deeply with that question when I saw it. Quite honestly, it changed my life forever. like we talk about the brain development right our brains are not entirely developed at 22 so i saw the most traumatic thing i could ever see in my life at 22 i experienced extreme abuse in the couple
你还拥有这样一档专门节目，致力于延续这个故事，或者说，分享更多不为人知的故事侧面。但你认为这在多大程度上改变了你对生活的视角和心态？你认为这显然产生了影响，但究竟是以什么方式？当你看到那个问题时，你深深地触动了我。老实说，它永远改变了我的生活。就像我们讨论过大脑发育一样，对吧？我们在22岁时大脑并未完全发育成熟。所以我22岁时目睹了我一生中能见过的最具有创伤性的事情，我在前几年——大约20岁左右时——经历了极端的虐待，所以那种虐待、那个事件改变了我对一切事物的反应方式。我的意思是，我看电影的方式都不同了。在我结婚期间，这甚至是我和前夫之间持续争吵的一个点，我前夫从来没有真正理解我为什么在看血腥电影时会有那种反应。我会捂住眼睛，或者让他关掉电影之类的，他会说，拜托，这都是假的。而我总是说，一旦你亲眼见过真的，你就再也不想看假的了。是的。而且他从未真正理解——我懂，关于我也有一大堆需要回顾的事情。我遇到他时，是在我妈妈被谋杀两个月后。所以，一个自称很懂爱的
years before right when i was around 20 like it became very extreme so that abuse that event changed the way i literally react to everything i mean i i watch movies differently i this was a continuing argument in my marriage while I was still married was my ex-husband never really kind of understood where I was coming from when I would watch a bloody movie. I would cover my eyes or I would have him turn it off or something and he'd be like, come on, it's just fake. And I always would say once you see it for real, you don't want to see it for fake. Yeah. And he never kind of, I know, I understand the instance of have a too. There's a lot to I'm back over there too. I was like, I met him when I was, I met him like two months after my mom was murdered. So, and here came in a
风度翩翩的男士（加引号）就这样出现了。现在，我从我的许多经历中了解到了一定程度的强制控制和情感虐待的许多机制。我得承认这一点。但它确实改变了我看待事物的方式、我对一切事物的看法，比如媒体中的暴力，就像我刚才说的，真实犯罪内容。我和我妈妈在成长过程中，我一直很喜欢真实犯罪题材。并不是我讨厌那种说法，因为你不能说“热爱”真实犯罪。
a gentleman quote unquote that was like very much love bombing me. I now know a lot of mechanisms of coercive control and emotional abuse to a certain degree from a lot of my relationships. I will say that. But it changed the way I just literally see things, my perspective on everything, violence in the media, like I was saying, true crime content. My mom and I growing up, I always loved true crime. Not that I hate that statement because you can't love true crime.
你可以热爱真实犯罪里面的内容。基本上，我并不是热爱犯罪本身。是的。你对这些故事很着迷。也许这是一种更好的说法。我是。我和我妈妈都这样，对吧？她书架上的所有书都是真实犯罪书籍。
Like you can love the content in true crime. I don't love crime, basically. Yes. You were fascinated by the stories. Maybe that's a good way. I was. My mom and I both were, right? That all of her books and her shelves were true crime books.
所以在事情的另一面，一旦我在很大程度上得到了疗愈，我就可以消费这些故事了。这确实让我以不同的方式看待一切，甚至连我一直非常感兴趣的真实犯罪领域也是如此。我处理人际关系的方式也不同了。我会触发不同的点，而其他人则不会。我患有很长时间的PTSD。所以，甚至只是当我去看演唱会时，也会感到非常不安。我一直都在想枪击事件。就像美国现在的状态，枪击事件和枪支暴力的数量，这，
So now on the other side of things, and once I was healed, to a large degree, I could consume those stories. And really, it made me see everything differently, even the true crime space that I had always really been interested in. I navigate my relationships differently. I'm triggered by different things and other people are. I had PTSD for a long time. So even just when I go to concerts, it's very unnerving. I'm thinking about shootings all the time. Like America's state right now, the amount of shootings and gun violence, it's,
我literally（简直）是以一种不同的方式在这个世界上穿行。我知道，我把孩子们送到学校，在门外向他们挥手告别。站在我旁边、和我做朋友的妈妈会听到我说，我只希望今天没有发生枪击事件。她看着我的眼神就像是在看一个疯子，而我会说，我知道他们身处和我一样的美国，但我经历过那种暴力。它就发生在我的家里。所以对于我来说，看到这种事在任何地方不断重演，仅仅是在我的国家继续生活下去，对我都具有高度的触发性。
I literally just navigate world differently. I know like I'll literally drop my kids off at school, wave to them through the gate. And the mom that I'm standing next to them in friends with, I'll be like, I just hope there isn't so shooting today. And she looks at me like, what the fuck? And I'm like, I know that they are in the same America as I am, but I have known a violence like that. It was in my home. So for me to see it replayed all the time everywhere, it is highly triggering for me to even just to persist in my country.
所以这是一种非常有层次感的状态，而且是一种永远的状态。你曾说过，某种程度上悲伤是永远的。创伤也可能如此。重大创伤，尤其是在你生命中某个时间点之前发生的重大创伤，在某种程度上是永远存在的。这并不是要确立一种——这是我世上最讨厌的说法。当你在谷歌上搜索“受害者”时，我的意思是，当你打开Instagram并输入“victim（受害者）”时，弹出的第一件事
So it's just a very layered state to be in and it's a forever state. You said grief is to a certain degree forever. Trauma can be too. Major trauma, especially I think before a certain point in your life is forever to a certain degree. That is not to establish a quote unquote, which is my least favorite statement in the world. And when you Google victim, I mean, when you go to Instagram and you type in victim, the first
就是“受害者心态”。我讨厌这个。但我并没有在延续这种说法。因为我认为那是地球上最令人不齿的词。因为当你谈论极端创伤或多年持续的创伤时，受害者身份在某种程度上是永远的。它不是一种心态，老实说，而是一种状态。当你被触发到那种程度时，PTSD在某种程度上可以是永远的。我看到过PTSD。我的意思是，这通常就是它的名字：复杂性创伤后应激障碍。我认为人们通常将其与“哦，你一定上过战场或经历过……”联系起来。是的，我想我们通常会从退伍军人的角度来思考它。但在世界上每天都在发生如此之多的日常创伤，这会以不同的方式影响我们所有人。不过，我想回到我们在最开始提到的那个概念，也就是逆境和苦难以及我们如何克服它们。现在，我认为每个人在某种程度上都处于这个光谱上，每个人都会经历一些事情。没有人能毫发无伤地度过一生，或者完全逃避某种程度的逆境。对你来说可能是创伤的事情，对我来说可能就不是超
thing that pops up is victim mentality. I hate that. But I'm not perpetuating. Like, I think that's the, the scummiest term on the planet. Because victimhood, when you're talking about extreme trauma or persisted trauma over the years, that is kind of forever. And it is a not a. mentality, but a state, to be honest. When you're that triggered, PTSD can be forever to a certain
级创伤。所以这也是其中的另一个层面。抱歉，请继续。不，我只是，我同意这一点。我总是说创伤是主观的。这是我们在节目中经常强调的一点。但你会如何面对苦难呢？你知道，我的受众中有很大一部分是30岁以下的人，他们可能正在经历那些将在此时此刻改变他们一生的事情，他们正在寻找答案。比如我该如何度过这一关？所以你是如何对待的，你是如何对待这段经历和这段旅程的？哇。其实我在书中写过这个。
degree. I see PTSD. I mean, that's generally what it's called. So complex post-traumatic stress disorder. And I think often people associate that with like, oh, you have to have gone to war or experienced like, yeah, I think we often think about it in terms of veterans. But there are so much everyday trauma that happens in the world, that is going to impact all of us in a different way. I do want to go back, though, to this idea that we mentioned at the very beginning, which is adversity and hardship and how we overcome that. Now, I think everyone in some capacity sits on this spectrum, everyone experiences something. No one goes through life unharmed or escaping kind of some level of adversity. And what might be traumatic, what might not be traumatic to you might be super
这是一个傻气的轶事，但它来自我的童年，它总结了我如何应对任何事情，因为这是我妈妈留给我的。老实说，我认为最主要的——在我生命中有许多成年人投资于我，并确保我一路走来取得成功。但妈妈是主力。绝对是的。她留给了我太多的教训。但我认为其中最大的一点——这也是我在生活中一遍又一遍重复的事情，以及我是如何度过一切的秘诀——就是我记得，
traumatic to me. So that is another level of that too. Sorry, go on. No, I just, I agree with that. I always say that trauma is subjective. That's like a massive thing that we stay on this show. But how would you approach hardship? You know, a massive part of my audience is people under the age of 30 who are probably experiencing, some of them will be experiencing the things that are going to alter their life right now, looking for answers. like how do I get through this? So how do you approach, how did you approach this experience and this journey? Wow. So I actually wrote in my book. This is a silly, but it's a silly anecdote, but it's from my childhood and it kind of summarizes how I take on anything because it's what my
我想我一直想成为——我知道我是一名领导者。但在我年轻的时候，没有人看到这一点。我的同龄人中没有任何人看到这一点。所以每年我都会在学校竞选班干部。而且我总是会输。甚至到了高中，甚至到了大学，信不信由你。就像我每年都参选。我依然在参选。
mom left me with. Like I honestly think the main, I had many adults in my life that invested in me and made sure I was successful along the way. But my mom was the main. Absolutely. She left me with so many lessons. But I think one of the biggest ones was, and it's something I repeated over and over and over again throughout my life. And it's how I get through everything is that I remember,
我喜欢这样。我输了。每一次，你知道我做了什么吗？每一次我输了，我妈妈……我可能中间有一两年没选，随便什么情况。但就像我妈妈会说，好吧，既然这次你输了，你明年打算竞选什么职位？这简直就是我妈妈训练我大脑的方式。所以当她在22岁离我而去时，我留下的直接反应就是，好吧，你接下来打算做什么？
I think I always wanted to be, I know I'm a leader. But nobody in my youth saw that. Like none of my peers saw that. So every year I would always run for office in school. And I would always lose. Even into high school, even into college, believe it or not. Like every single year I ran. I still run.
她并不是那种……她只是训练我要一直坚持下去。这种顽强精神是我整个生活中一直存在的主题，是她留给我的财富。如果没有她的提醒，如果没有她的催促——当我22岁失去她时，这一切就全留给我自己去面对了。而这正是我所做的。我认为坚持不懈和顽强很大程度上与自我对话有关。我认为。即使有时这种对话是负面的，当我有时感到自己无能为力或缺乏信心去做一件我真的很想做的事情时，我仍然听到那个声音在说，但你还是要试一试，
I love that. I lost. And every time, you know what I did? Every time I lost my mom. And I maybe took off a year here or there, whatever. But like my mom would say, okay, so if you lost this time, what are you going to run for next year? And that was literally how my mom trained my brain. So when I, she was gone at 22, I was literally left with, okay, so what are you going to do next?
因为你已经处理过了——我当时已经处理过了可能发生的最糟糕的事情。写作的退稿信之类的其他任何事情，根本不算什么。我刚刚亲眼目睹了我妈妈被谋杀。就像，你知道，我就是这样挺过来的。我知道这听起来有点扭曲、黑暗，但我真的是通过对自己说“那是可能发生的的最糟糕的事情了”来挺过去的。剩下的情况一定得比这更好。
It wasn't like, she just trained me that you always keep going. That tenacity was like the main theme in my entire life that she always left me with. And without her reminders and without her, you know, firing up my butt, like, that was left on me when I hit 22 and I was left without her. And that's just what I did. I kind of perseverance and tenacity, I think, has a lot to do with self-talk. I think it. And even when it was sometimes negative, when I felt ineffective at times or I lacked the confidence to do something I really wanted to do, I still had that voice saying, but you're going to try
并不是我觉得世界欠我什么。我知道未来我仍会经历创伤，此后的人生中也确实经历过。但这把事情放到了一个正确的视角中。我想有时人们会问我，你是怎么活下来的？而我唯一的反问是，唯一的替代选择就是活不下去。你只能站起来。你只能一步一个脚印地走下去。我现在的状态终于能够真正保持正念了。
because you've already dealt with the, I already dealt with the worst thing it could possibly have happened. Anything else, like rejection letters for writing, there are nothing. I just saw my mom murder. Like, you know, that is literally how I got through. I know that sounds a little twisted. dark, but I literally got through by saying that was the worst that could have ever happened. The rest has to be better.
我想我在那些年里只是给了自己一些宽容。而且我可能没有像——我有PTSD。就像我说的，那会让你无法保持正念。你无法活在当下。你活在焦虑、恐惧、恐慌和所有这些情绪中。但我挺过来的方式就是字面意义上知道，未来还有更好的。世界曾向我展示过美好。我妈妈向我展示过美好。
And it's not that I feel that the world owes me anything. I know trauma will still happen to me in the future and it has in my life since. But it's put things into perspective. I think sometimes we think how people will ask me, how did you survive? And my only question is the only alternative is not. And you just get up. You put one foot in front of the other. I'm finally in a place right now where I can be really mindful.
老师们向我展示过美好。我自己也向我展示过美好，所有这一切也是如此。无论家里发生了什么，我所有的努力都得到了回报。我想，我妈妈留给我的另一件事就是：失败的唯一方式就是不去尝试。所以人生中失败的唯一途径，或者说唯一的结果就是放弃，而我不能放弃。就像，是的，我知道——显然心理治疗也真的很有帮助。是的，我是它的忠实粉丝。
I think I just gave myself grace in all of those years. And I maybe wasn't as my, I had PTSD. Like I said, that makes you not mindful. You can't live in the moment. You live in your anxiety and your fear and your panic and all of that. But the way I got through is just literally knowing that there is better. The world had shown me better. My mom showed me better.
不过老实说，并非所有的治疗都有帮助。并非所有的治疗师都有用。我认为关键在于找到对的治疗师。我确实认为存在一种谬论，即任何治疗都有帮助。我确实遇到过一些有害的治疗师，从各种真正意义上的“好心办坏事”开始，比如在第二次见面时——显然治疗师经常会问你，是什么让你来到这里的？显然我说的第一件事就是我妈妈的谋杀案。而在与这位女士的第二次面谈中，她说，好的，那么你和妈妈的关系怎么样？你每天还是每周都和她说话？而我想，等等，等一下，这对我是有害的，因为她在某种程度上甚至记不得我是谁了。还有其他的，还有其他形式的伤害。
teachers had showed me better. I'd shown myself better and all of that too. No matter what was going on at home that like all of my hard work paid off. And I like I think the other thing my mom always left me with was like the only way to fail is not try. So the only way to fail at life or to just is just to give up and I couldn't give up. Like I yeah, that's I know it like also obviously therapy really helped. Yes, but big fans of that. Yeah, and I have to be honest, though, not all therapy helped. Not all therapists are helpful. I think it's the right therapist.
但关键在于，一个健康的治疗师会为你提供工具，不会让你觉得余生每周都必须去找他们，这才是极好的空间。我认为治疗是一个反思的空间，能提供度过难关的资源，但它并非灵丹妙药。我不认为任何东西能成为灵丹妙药。运动一直是我度过任何难关的极好资源。在我20岁时，老实说，我的应对方式并不那么健康。
I definitely think that there's this fallacy that any therapy helps. I've really been to some harmful therapists from anything really like a benevolent harmful where like the second meeting, like obviously therapists often ask you, what brings you here? Obviously, one of the first things I say is my mom's murder. And the second interview with this one woman, she said, okay, so how's your relationship with your mom? do talk to her daily or weekly and I was like, wait, hold on, that was harmful to me because she couldn't even remember who I was at a certain degree. There have other, there have been other ones that have been harmful in other ways.
比如我没有被诊断出进食障碍，但有时我确实有饮食失调的问题。当无法控制其他事情时，我通过这种方式来控制。这是一个重大问题。饮食失调与经历过创伤之间存在很大联系。
But the point is, is that a healthy therapist that gives you tools and doesn't make you think that you have to live by going to them every week for the rest of your life is a great space. I think that knowing therapy is a space for reflection and resources to get through something. but it's not an end-all be-all. I don't think anything can be an end-all be-all. Exercise has always been a really great resource for me in getting through anything. In my 20s, I honestly coped a little unhealthy.
绝对是的。我把那更多地看作是一种症状。由于我所有的焦虑，那段时间我还经常受到严重胃痛的困扰。当时没有任何诊断结果。我不是对麸质过敏。我不是这个。我不是那个。所以我确实相信，最终，
Like I dealt with not a diagnosed eating disorder, but I definitely had disordered eating at times. That was something I controlled when I couldn't control other things. Which is a big thing. A big link to disorder eating is when you've gone through trauma. up. Absolutely. And I saw that as more of a symptom. I was also plagued with really bad stomach aches around that time too because of all my anxiety. There was no diagnosis. I couldn't, I wasn't gluten intolerant. I wasn't this. I wasn't that. So I do believe I eventually like,
你知道，我只是——我离婚了。我逃离了一些有毒的环境。我花时间和精力进行疗愈，并且我最终繁荣了。所以就像投资于自我一样，我认为自我照顾一直是最重要的，而自我照顾可以是法律上的照顾。它可以是治疗性的照顾，比如系统化的心理疗法。它可以像是一对一的谈话治疗。它可以是写我的书。所有这些事情，我，你知道的，我非常年轻的时候就开始写书了，还在20多岁的时候。
you know, I just, I got a divorce. I escaped some toxic situations. I put in the time and the work in healing and I thrived. So just like investing in myself, I think self-care has been one of the most, and self-care can be legal care. It could be therapeutic care, like in a regimented therapy. It could be like, you know, one-on-one talk therapy. It could be writing my book. Any of those things, I, you know, I started my book really young to in my 20s.
你知道的，我刚刚，我离婚了。我逃离了一些有毒的环境。我花时间和精力去疗愈，并且我成功了。所以就像投资自己一样，我认为自我关怀是最重要的之一，而且自我关怀也可以是法律上的关怀。它可以是治疗性的关怀，比如进行规律的治疗。它可以像，你知道的，一对一的谈话治疗。它可以是写我的书。所有这些事情，我，你知道的，我在很年轻的时候就开始写书了，在我20多岁的时候。
it took me a long time to finish. But like all of these things were practices I needed. Oh, I started writing and doing live pieces to share my grief with people that were also grieving or people that were mothers. And all of that really showed me I wasn't alone. And that has been a big saving grace as well as community, building a community around not like off of the trauma, but building a community around or surrounding the trauma. to kind of encapsulate it and to put finite borders around it and to heal together. Which I think is remarkable community is such a healing force. And, you know, you lost your mother on that day. But also you, you know, your brother sounds like an awful person, is an awful person. But you also lost him in the sense that like suddenly you had, there was no family.
我花了很长时间才完成。但所有这些都是我需要的练习。我开始写作并进行现场表演，与同样在悲伤的人或身为人母的人分享我的悲伤。所有这一切真正向我表明，我并不孤单。这是一种极大的救赎，社区也是如此，围绕着创伤——不是利用创伤，而是围绕创伤建立一个社区。将其包裹起来，为它设定明确的界限，然后一起治愈。我认为这非常了不起，社区是一种如此强大的治愈力量。而且，你知道，你在那天失去了母亲。但同时，你知道，你的弟弟听起来像个糟糕透顶的人，他确实是个糟糕透顶的人。但你也失去了他，因为突然之间，你没有了家庭。
I had no family. Yeah, my whole family. Yeah, gone. And I think that building community is something I say to like everyone. It feeling less alone just makes everything seem more manageable. And I should have said that from the beginning. You said, how did you get through? I honestly, in my book, I explained how I got through those four years just to convict him.
我没有家庭。是的，我的整个家庭。是的，都没了。我认为建立社区是我对每个人都会说的话。感觉不那么孤单会让一切看起来都更容易应对。我本该从一开始就这么说的。你问过，我是怎么熬过来的？老实说，在我的书中，我解释了我是如何熬过那四年的，只是为了给他定罪。
And in it, the recurring theme I would say is the people my mom left me with, the community that I built through my work, through her, through everything, through school, through my sorority, everything. That all was literally what carried me. When I couldn't carry myself, those people were there. And then, you know, once I started sharing my story more publicly, the people that reach out to me and say, I'm a victim of sibling abuse as well. You know, in my research, I found out like 50% of American kids are affected by sibling
在书中，我可以说贯穿始终的主题是我妈妈留给我的那些人，是我通过我的工作、通过她、通过一切、通过学校、通过我的姐妹会建立的社区，一切。所有这些真的是支撑我走过来的人。当我无法支撑自己时，那些人在那里。然后，你知道的，当我开始更公开地分享我的故事时，联系我的人说，我也是同胞虐待的受害者。你知道，在我的研究中，我发现大约百分之五十的美国孩子在某种程度上受到了同胞
abuse in some manner. And I'm sure you talk about abuse in the definition of it at times. But, you know, abuse can be anything where they're using a position of power or, you know, to manipulate a behavior. So that is, you know, emotional, physical, you know, and I get messages all the time from people saying, I was abused by my brother. Or women who say, thank you for showing me what my son could potentially do. And just the allowance to know that we're not alone is huge. I write back to everybody that writes to me. And even like, well, I'll get to the, but like even when my book came out, my uncle hit me up. My dad is, my, my dad's
虐待的影响。我确信你在某些时候也会讨论虐待的定义。但是，你知道，虐待可以是任何利用权力地位来操纵行为的事情。所以，你知道，这是情感上的、身体上的，你知道，我一直收到人们的信息说，我被我哥哥虐待了。或者女性说，谢谢你让我看到我儿子潜在可能会做出的行为。仅仅是那种知道我们并不孤单的许可，就意义重大。我会回复每一个给我写信的人。甚至，嗯，我会说到那个，但是甚至当我的书出版时，我叔叔联系了我。我爸爸的，我爸爸的
brother and he said thank you for naming something that I went through at the hands of your dad. Oh my goodness. And I had known that. He had never shared that with me, but my mom had told me some like stories about it. And so I helped, like this was in within my home. But in the messages I write back to people that send me like, you know, thank you. I went through this. I'm so glad to know I'm not alone.
哥哥，他说谢谢你把我也在你爸爸手下经历过的事情说出来。哦，天哪。我其实是知道这一点的。他从未跟我分享过，但我妈妈曾跟我讲过一些相关的故事。所以我有帮助，这其实就发生在我家里。但在我回复那些发信息对我说，你知道，谢谢你的人时，我说，我经历了这些。我很高兴知道我并不孤单。
I know. And I read a variation of this to everybody, but basically like my heart breaks for people who go through something similar, but it gives each of us a little bit of solace and knowing that we aren't alone. And that it's literally in the sharing is the lifting. When you share a load with someone, they're literally helping you lift it up. So that is what what community did for me too is that when I shared when I was rawest, I had someone to go to. I utilized friends, therapists, family. I'm so blessed to have family. I mean, oh my God, that's massive. Yeah. So many good things. So many good things. So many good.
我知道。我向每个人都读过这段话的变体，但基本上就是，对于经历类似事情的人，我感到心碎，但这让我们每个人都得到了一点慰藉，因为我们知道自己并不孤单。而且，分享本身就是一种解脱。当你与某人分担重担时，他们实际上是在帮你把它抬起来。这就是社区对我的意义所在——当我处于最脆弱的状态进行分享时，我有人可以倾诉。我向朋友、治疗师、家人寻求帮助。我很幸运能有家人。我是说，哦，天哪，这太重要了。是的。那么多美好的事情。那么多美好的事情。那么多美好的。
Yes, I'm very blessed. Oh, I love that you. Which sounds very weird to say that. I love that. But I made an interview about my mom's murder, but yeah. Well, it just feels so dichotomous, but I, the truth's going to be true. Exactly. I totally agree with that.
是的，我非常幸运。哦，我很高兴你。虽然说这话听起来很奇怪。我很高兴这一点。但我做了一个关于我妈妈谋杀案的采访，不过是的。嗯，感觉太二元对立了，但事实就是事实。没错。我完全同意这一点。
I want to ask you one final question before we wrap up. And I think the big thing that I take away from talking to you is that people who experience these things should be in charge of their stories. It's not for other people to interpret. It's not for other people to use as entertainment. You know, obviously there is a core element of education. But if we as the audience, and I'm going to include myself in that as well, because listening to you speak is just incredible.
在结束之前，我想问你最后一个问题。我认为从与你的交谈中我获得的最大收获是，经历过这些事情的人应该掌控自己的故事。这不是供其他人解读的。这不是供其他人当作娱乐来使用的。你知道，显然其中有一个核心的教育元素。但是如果我们作为观众——我也把自己算在其中，因为听你说话实在是太不可思议了——
But if we as the audience could take away one thing from your story, what would you like it to be? Well, first of all, thank you for interpreting what you did thus far. That was a great takeaway, you said. You took away that each person should be in charge of their own narrative and have the power to tell it. That's, I absolutely agree. What I was thinking is actually, like I mentioned at the beginning of this, you asked how April 17th went, which was actually my brother's final sentencing, which just happened out of nowhere. And at the end of my victim impact statement, which I almost didn't get to make because he pled guilty.
但是如果我们作为观众能从你的故事中带走一件事，你希望它是什么？嗯，首先，谢谢你对你目前所做解读的肯定。那是一个很棒的收获，正如你所说。你得出的结论是，每个人都应该掌控自己的叙事，并拥有讲述它的力量。那是，我完全同意。我其实在想的是，就像我在开始时提到的那样，你问我4月17日过得怎么样，那其实是我弟弟最终宣判的日子，这是毫无预兆地突然发生的。在我宣读受害者影响陈述的最后——我差点没机会宣读，因为他认罪了，
and then said, if she makes the statement, I'm going to retract all my guilties. Like, he literally tried to fuck with me with that. Yeah. Oh, my God. And the judge kind of put him in his place a little bit, but then he talked through my whole victim impact statement, but whatever.
然后又说，如果她宣读这个陈述，我就要撤回我所有的认罪。就像，他 literalmente 试图用这个来搞我。是的。哦，天哪。法官有点当场压制了他，但他还是在我宣读整个受害者影响陈述时一直插话，不过随便啦。
I was a badass. I kept pausing every time he talked. And even though the judge wanted me to keep going, I did not. But at the end of it, I said, and that's what the takeaway will be, a long story short. I'm sorry, I'm a talker.
我当时表现得很霸气。他每次说话我都停下来。尽管法官希望我继续，但我没有。但在最后，我说，这就是结论，长话短说。抱歉，我很啰嗦。
I don't know. The thing that I want everybody to take away from my story, from mom's story, from the trauma that we faced, from everything that's ensued after is that, and especially from my brother's actions, it's that one person's actions can deeply affect someone else's trajectory. We see that all the time, right? Like in a million different ways. but I actually saw that recently at that hearing on April 17th, which I actually give a full rundown. I'm going to release an episode in a little while about like the update, but, and how that changed my life.
我不知道。我希望每个人从我的故事、从妈妈的故事、从我们所面临的创伤、从之后发生的一切中汲取的教训是，特别是从我弟弟的行为中，那就是：一个人的行为可以深深地影响另一个人的轨迹。我们一直都能看到这一点，对吧？以一百种不同的方式。但我最近在4月17的那场听证会上真正看到了这一点，其实我会做一个全面的回顾。过一会儿我会发布一集关于最新情况的节目，以及这如何改变了我的生活。
But for those who don't know, this was your, so your brother's final hearing date was on April 17th. It was a sentencing for a new crime. They also went backwards and gave me some more justice for other, for my mom's murder as well as the another crime, the death threat. He was threatening me. Yes. So at that sentencing, my last statement was again, I said, like my brother's actions proof, one person's choices can immensely affect someone else's trajectory.
但对于那些不知道的人来说，这是你的，也就是你弟弟的最后听证会日期是在4月17日。那是对一件新罪行的宣判。他们还回顾过去，为我妈妈的谋杀案以及另一项罪行（即死亡威胁）争取到了更多的正义。他一直在威胁我。是的。所以在那个宣判上，我的最后陈述又是，我说道，就像我弟弟的行为所证明的，一个人的选择可以极大地影响另一个人的轨迹。
But the DA proved me that to me too that day. He believed in me. He made a little bit of more effort. He did. He went a little bit of above and beyond his job. And he changed my life forever. And I think that just knowing that your actions carry. much weight. Even you listening. Everybody, I mean to say even you, especially you listening because
但那天地方检察官也向我证明了这一点。他相信我。他付出了一点点更多的努力。他真的这么做了。他超越了本职工作，做了一些额外的事情。他永远改变了我的生活。我认为，只要知道你的行为分量很重。甚至是你，在听节目的你。每个人，我是说甚至是你，尤其是正在听节目的你，因为
you're listening and leaving yourself open to change and evolving. But everybody's actions carry immense weight. And we all have the great ability to change things. And I really do challenge everyone to step outside a little bit of their comfort zone and do more for others and try to just, you know, go that extra little mile. It might make a huge, indifference for people. I love that mentality. And I just think that even with mental health and everything, you know, people that might be struggling, being there for friends, whatever it is, just doing a little bit more, giving that compliment when you see somebody walk by. You don't know what their day has been like. Whatever it is, I do believe in the power of individual,
你在倾听，并且让自己对改变和不断发展保持开放的心态。但每个人的行为都带有巨大的分量。我们所有人都有巨大的能力去改变事物。我真的向每个人发出挑战，稍微走出一点舒适区，为他人多做一点，试着去，你知道的，多走那么一小步。它可能会给人们带来巨大的改变。我喜欢这种心态。而且我只是认为，即使面对心理健康和一切，你知道，那些可能正在苦苦挣扎的人，陪伴在朋友身边，无论是什么，只是多做一点，当你看到有人走过时给予一个赞美。你不知道他们那天过得怎么样。无论是什么，我都相信个人的力量，
I mean, I believe in individual power. I believe in you, the listener. Amy, I love that you we've ended the show on that note because I do just think it's like the most beautiful trajectory of this story, right? From the start of this episode, hearing what you went through and not just what happened on that day that your mother passed away, but everything from childhood to now and the fact that you're saying to us, just do that little bit extra for people because people are good and think about others. It's just so beautiful. It's just so beautiful. And I just think, the theme of this, the topic that we, you know, this all links to is like, overcoming adversity and hardship and your story through that.
我是说，我相信个人的力量。我相信你，听众朋友。艾米，我很高兴我们以这种基调结束节目，因为我真的认为这是这个故事最美丽的轨迹，对吧？从这期节目的开始，听到你的经历，不仅仅是发生在你母亲去世那天的遭遇，还有从童年到现在的经历，以及你对我们说的话：只管为人们多做那么一点点，因为人们是善良的，要为他人着想。这真是太美好了。真是太美好了。而且我只是认为，我们讨论的主题，这一切都与之相关，那就是——克服逆境和艰难险阻，以及你通过这些经历展现的故事。
And it's just really, I don't know, really inspiring to me to hear that you can still have that, that mind frame and mindset and that you've done so much good stuff for the world. Like, I can't wait to watch that, that vice. Is it a documentary or? Yeah, you know, there's just a tiny blip. I don't even know if I'll be in it, although they did ask for, like, how to spell my name. So I think they, but my, my friends who are actually releasing a podcast tomorrow, they're, they're kind of coinciding it.
这真的让我，我不知道，真的很受启发，听到你仍然能拥有那种心态和思维方式，并且你为世界做了这么多美好的事情。比如，我等不及要看那个，那个副主编。是纪录片还是？是的，你知道，只有一个小插曲。我什至不知道我会不会出现在里面，尽管他们确实询问了，比如怎么拼写我的名字。所以我认为他们，但是我的朋友们明天实际上要发布一个播客，他们，他们正在某种程度上配合推出。
They are kind of the main focuses of the, of the documentary, but it kind of goes through. And like, they just actually, they interview a whole bunch of really famous, I hate to say that, victims from, and just kind of get their take on how the whole genre go. Yeah. I guess it's today for you, though. I'm going to go and watch it after this, actually. I'm going to sit down and watch it. and probably send it to some of my friends because I think that is,
他们算是纪录片的主要关注点，但它大致讲述了过程。就像，他们实际上采访了一大批非常有名的——我讨厌这么说——来自各个领域的受害者，只是想了解他们对整个流派发展的看法。是的。不过对你来说今天就要播出了吧。我待会儿就要去看。我要坐下来看。可能还会发给一些我的朋友，因为我认为那，
it's just, it's interesting. I think sometimes we need to be a little bit more conscious about how we consume our media. And I think often in the time we think like, I don't want to spend less time on my phone or yada, yada, yada. But it's actually like sometimes a bit more ethical than that. So I think this is, it's just an interesting, a really interesting, fascinating perspective that I'm glad you were able to share.
这很有趣。我认为有时我们需要更有意识地对待我们消费媒体的方式。我认为很多时候我们觉得，我不想在手机上花更少的时间，或者诸如此类的话。但这实际上有时比这更具道德感。所以我认为这，这是一个有趣且真正迷人的视角，我很高兴你能分享它。
And I want to thank you very sincerely for coming on. Thank you to be honest. Thank you so much for opening your platform to my story, to leaving your heart open and listening. Thank you just for the thoughtful questions and for the care through this whole process. That's a whole other facet. I know this is not a true crime podcast, but we talked a lot about ethics. So thank you for contributing whether you are a true crime content or not. You are an ethical show that creates a safe space for victims like me.
我非常真诚地感谢你能来。老实说，谢谢你。非常感谢你向我的故事开放你的平台，敞开心扉并倾听。谢谢你提出周到的问题以及在整个过程中的关怀。这是另一个方面。我知道这不是一个真实犯罪播客，但我们讨论了很多关于道德的话题。所以谢谢你的贡献，无论你是不是真实犯罪内容的创作者。你是一个合乎道德的节目，为像我这样的受害者创造了一个安全空间。
And I just appreciate you doing that. and contributing such a thoughtful show to the conversation and such awareness. That is the biggest compliment I've ever received. I'm never going to forget that. Oh, my God. I love you, Jennifer. We're just having such an emotional time over here. And where can people find you?
我很感激你能这样做，并为这场对话贡献了一个如此深思熟虑的节目和如此高的觉悟。这是我收到的最高赞美。我永远不会忘记这一点。哦，天哪。我爱你，詹妮弗。我们在这里度过了一段非常感人的时光。人们在哪里可以找到你？
I think that everyone needs to listen to your show. Can you plug yourself a little bit, please? Yes, thank you. So personally, you can find me on all platforms. at Amy, A-M-Y, Fia as and Boy, and Chessler. That's my last name, C-H-E-S-L-E-R. And then my podcast, which recently came out. And again, I kind of go through history, and I'm interviewing victims of relatively
我认为每个人都应该听你的节目。你能稍微宣传一下自己吗？好的，谢谢。所以就个人而言，你可以在所有平台上找到我，用户名是Amy（A-M-Y），Fia（像Boy里的F），然后是Chessler。那是我的姓氏，C-H-E-S-L-E-R。然后是我的播客，最近刚上线。再说一次，我回顾历史，我采访的都是犯下相对
notorious crimes or just crimes that happen consistently and talking about how navigating their after story, basically, navigating the after-the-trauma, how it affects them to share their story in the media, how, you know, how just like navigating the legal system, how that's affected their trajectory. And that show is called What Came Next. You can find What Came Next on your preferred podcasting platform. I know I mentioned my book before. The title is Working for Justice, One Family's Tale of Murder, Betrayal, and Healing.
声名狼藉的罪行的受害者，或者只是那些不断发生的罪行，并讨论如何度过他们的后续故事，基本上，如何度过创伤之后的生活，这如何影响他们在媒体上分享自己的故事，你知道的，如何度过法律系统，这如何影响了他们的生活轨迹。那个节目的名字叫《接下来发生了什么》（What Came Next）。你可以在你首选的播客平台上找到《接下来发生了什么》。我知道我之前提过我的书。书名是《为正义而战：一个家庭的谋杀、背叛与治愈传奇》（Working for Justice, One Family's Tale of Murder, Betrayal, and Healing）。
And that, honestly, that was 14 years in the making. And I can't go through an interview without mentioning it because I think it was, it's a beautiful tribute to my mom. I actually include some diary entries of my mom's in throughout the book. So I just think like it's important again, like you said, to give victims voices. And I think I did that even in my mom in the books. Thank you again, Amy, for coming on and sharing your story. As always, if you think there is a friend, a family member, a colleague who would benefit from Amy's perspective and what she had to say today, feel free to share this episode with them. She was so generous. brave in coming on and I very much appreciate it.
老实说，那是历时14年才完成的。我无法在不提及它的情况下完成一次采访，因为我认为它，这是对我妈妈的美丽致敬。我实际上在书中的各处收录了我妈妈的一些日记条目。所以我只是认为，就像你说的，赋予受害者声音再次变得很重要。我认为我做到了这一点，甚至在我妈妈的书里也是如此。再次感谢艾米来分享你的故事。像往常一样，如果你认为有哪个朋友、家庭成员或同事会受益于艾米对今天的见解和言论，请随时与他们分享这期节目。她非常慷慨勇敢地来到节目中，我对此非常感激。
If you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to give it a five-star review on Apple podcast, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. And if you want to provide some feedback, if you have an episode suggestion, you just want to reach out and say hi, follow us on Instagram at that psychology podcast. And we will be back next week with another episode. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kea Game. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
如果你喜欢这期节目，请随时在苹果播客、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方给它一个五星评价。如果你想提供一些反馈，如果你有节目的建议，或者只是想打个招呼，请在Instagram上关注我们@thatpsychology podcast。我们下周将带着另一期节目回归。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基亚·盖姆（Kea Game）主持的《艰难学习》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都实在不安全去进行的诚实对话，但你们是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。
How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHR radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is only. Also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
有多少男人穿着铠甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在IHeart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。2%。这就是当只有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%.
在我的播客《2%》（2%）中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立精神坚韧、健康和韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是数字的2%。
On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all The same prolific con artist. They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
在IHeart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都遇到了同一个多产的骗子时。她们采取了行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。
We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam Jay
我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回看》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，对我和说那是我的一个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。在每一集中，我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着通过我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家来理解我们是如何熬过来的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈80年代。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看》。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. in. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个IHeart播客。保证真人出品。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可留下评论。